[Musique]
M. Wayne,
vous savez que vous pourriez vraiment faire plus
pour cette ville,
votre famille a une histoire de
philanthropie, mais pour autant que je sache,
vous ne faites rien
si je suis élu, je veux changer cela,
merci
oh mon  dieu
je vais aller te rendre hommage veux tu
m'attendre je vais continuer
ça  pas encore hey
mr wayne
[musique]
vous avez des gens qui le recherchent jim a
envoyé quelques gars chez lui rien
que sa femme disant qu'elle n'avait pas de nouvelles
de lui
[musique]
[musique
] redescendez
[applaudissements]
sortez de la  voiture et montrez vos mains
sortez
[Musique]
christ c'est colson
il y a une bombe autour
[Musique]
nettoyons cet endroit maintenant
le batman a fait une descente pg-13 l'a expérimenté
dans imax seulement les batteurs le 4 mars
vous